y
[Música]
su hijo nunca va a caminar
su hijo va a presentar severas
limitaciones de por vida si no hablan
desde los 7 olvídense ya no va a hablar
no no no se ilusione tiene que aceptar
las cosas como son estas son palabras
que tantos padres escuchamos en un
estado de completa angustia confusión y
desesperación porque cuando un hijo
recibe un diagnóstico aparece como una
sentencia que lo condena y asegura la
limitación sin embargo un diagnóstico no
es una sentencia si es un cambio de
planes inesperado intenso y con un
montón de posibilidades por delante
por otro lado médicos y profesionales
que ponen un techo o un límite a un niño
solamente por un diagnóstico no están
actualizados sobre los últimos avances
científicos y sus aplicaciones prácticas
ellos no están actualizados punto
autismo deje de encefalopatías lesiones
cerebrales desórdenes genéticos motrices
de la conducta del lenguaje podemos
cambiar el rumbo de lo posible gracias a
la capacidad de cambio del cerebro
gracias a la neuroplasticidad todo
sucede en el cerebro mover un brazo una
pierna caminar hablar leer interactuar
con otros cualquier habilidad que
deseamos que un niño alcance debe formar
las conexiones y patrones neuronales en
su cerebro que lo posibiliten y esta
formación de patrones neuronales no es
algo que viene predeterminado en el
sistema es algo que se crea en el
cerebro a partir de las experiencias que
el niño tiene por eso si nacemos en
argentina hablamos español y si nacemos
en turquía hablamos turco
porque es la experiencia la que moldea
el aprendizaje aprendizaje y formación
de patrones neuronales son lo mismo y en
este proceso intervienen muchas y
complejas variables sin embargo yo hoy
quiero hablarles de algo mucho más
simple y determinante a su vez la
experiencia en sí misma el aprendizaje
no se puede forzar no se puede obligar a
imponer no funciona de esa manera no
podemos generar desde afuera las
conexiones neuronales en el cerebro del
niño el aprendizaje debe surgir en el
niño desde el niño si un niño no mueve
sus piernas por una lesión cerebral la
mayoría de los abordajes tradicionales
se las va a mover realizando ejercicios
repetitivos de manera mecánica incluso
con un alto nivel de exigencia sin
observar cuál es la experiencia que el
niño tiene con eso que se está haciendo
en su propio cuerpo
he visto a niños llorando gritando
generando mayor contracción muscular
mayor resistencia alejándose a la
posibilidad de mover las piernas el
cerebro experimenta la limitación
y entonces la limitación se refuerza
aprende que no puede mover las piernas
con emociones además de miedo
inseguridad estrés un niño nos debe
exigirse esforzarse y bancársela porque
tiene una encefalopatía de hecho cuanto
más fácil cuanto más placenteras la
experiencia más rápido se aprende cada
experiencia cuenta con cualquier
actividad por ejemplo sacarle la media
desde la forma en que sostenemos la
pierna ya es significativa para el niño
usar nuestra atención para convocar la
suya moverla lento buscando su respuesta
su participación algún tipo de
anticipación de registro de lo que
sucede brindando seguridad confianza
conectando con el niño y saben que
aparece la respuesta a veces la primera
vez que hacemos esto de esta forma o la
segunda o la número 20 o la 200 no
importa cuando importa que aparezca es
condición necesaria para que esas
piernas se muevan que el niño comience a
hacer
no importa cuántas veces lo hagamos
nosotros si no es él quien las mueve no
las mueve y esta participación puede
comenzar por mover el dedo del pie por
sentir cómo sale la media del pie por
ser parte de la experiencia aparte
genuina
balbás férulas y prestadores mochilas de
peso y otros tantos aparatos que imponen
externamente que buscan forzar a que el
sistema haga lo que no está haciendo por
sí mismo a veces estas experiencias son
tan extremas para los niños que ellos se
desconectan de su propio sentir y esto
sólo resta
he visto niños con dificultades
emocionales funcionales y estructurales
debido al uso de estos aparatos los
modelos terapéuticos y de rehabilitación
que conocen sobre el funcionamiento del
cerebro que se basan en la
neuroplasticidad y el aprendizaje
entienden la importancia de no forzar de
no restringir el movimiento de ir con el
sistema la importancia de las posturas
como formas dinámicas y no estáticas en
donde la atención la variación y la
conciencia corporal son el punto de
partida de cualquier cambio orgánico y
real
cuando un niño tiene un tiempo de
aprendizaje diferente al esperado el
entorno debe amoldarse al niño y no al
revés y nosotros somos parte de ese
entorno cómo te llamas lindos pedro se
llama pedro pedrito cuántos años tienes
pedro 4 tiene 4 cumplió la semana pasada
respondemos por ellos los interrumpimos
pedro tráela mucho que nos vamos al
jardín dale pedro la mochila vamos estoy
acá la mocha y que está arriba de la
mesa la mochila verde que te regalo a la
abuela consignado la abuela a pedir la
abu dabu mirtha se llamada le trae la
noche y vamos con las dos manos pedro
con las dos manos de la manija la manita
que ésta deja sólo hacemos
es tal nuestra velocidad nuestro ritmo
nuestro nivel de automático que nos
volvemos un factor de desorganización de
la experiencia que ellos tienen tiempo
los niños requieren tiempo si están en
proceso de aprendizaje y algo no les
sale requieren más tiempo
pedro trae la mochila
10 segundos en silencio dándole espacio
dándole la oportunidad facilitando la
experiencia de hacer tienen que vivir la
experiencia de hacer facilitando la
experiencia de responder tienen que
vivir la experiencia de responder
tenemos que darles estos diez segundos
que sin duda se irán transformando en 7
4 1 y 0 pero que debe comenzar por el
tiempo real que les toma hoy porque si
no lo hacen no lo hacen y se aprende a
no hacer a no poder a fracasar y con el
tiempo muchas veces no quieren
intentarlo
niños con autismo a los que se les
indica todo lo que tienen que hacer
abrir la canilla poner las manos en el
agua agarra el jabón frontal en tus
manos deja el jabón enjuaga las manos
cerrar la canilla agarra la toalla
sécate las manos deja la toalla apagar
la luz cerrar la puerta
saluda a la maestra saca el cuaderno
sentate párate y al fin
con estas experiencias en el mejor de
los casos los niños aprenden a responder
y muchas veces se vuelven buenos
respondedores que solo dicen gracias o
se sacan la campera o usan el tenedor
cuando alguien se lo sindica no hay
intención no hay deseo no hay interés
porque no le conocen porque no pudieron
auto generar la experiencia debido al
diagnóstico pero el entorno nunca
facilitó la experiencia en otros casos
cuando los niños no responden a una
consigna directamente se los manipula
físicamente se les pone las manos debajo
del agua se les pone la habana en la
canilla y se los hace girar se los lleva
de acá para allá se elegirá la cara para
que nos miren
y esto con niños de 2 y 3 años de 4 de 5
y 7 de 11 15 de 16
cuál es la experiencia que ellos tienen
la intención es enseñarles ahora qué es
lo que ellos aprenden de estas dos cosas
no necesariamente coinciden
podemos facilitar experiencias que
promuevan el interés la intención la
espontaneidad el deseo la curiosidad la
autonomía
vale más algo realizado una vez de
manera espontánea y con intención propia
que algo realizado diez mil veces
dirigido y sin un sentido propio
como madre y como profesional busco
observar la experiencia completa que
tienen los niños y otra variable que he
encontrado muy relevante es la mirada
del otro y nosotros somos ese otro que
mira
muchos expertos tienen una mirada casi
exclusiva sobre las limitaciones de los
niños me llegan informes de otros
profesionales con una lista de todo lo
que no pueden hacer
lucila no camina no mueve su brazo
izquierdo no tiene juego simbólico
presenta un severo retraso en su
desarrollo los padres reciben estos
mismos informes con un efecto devastador
cuál es el sentido de esto algunos dirán
que hay que ser realistas no que las
limitaciones son reales
y yo me pregunto no son igual de reales
las cosas que sí puede hacer ese niño
que hay más real que lo que observamos
que sí sucede debemos mirar a los niños
desde sus habilidades
debemos valorar cada cosa que pueden
hacer creer en ellos confiar en ellos
hagan una lista de todas las cosas que
si pueden hacer los niños
la mirada del otro amplifica la
experiencia una mirada sobre la
limitación amplifica la limitación
debilita nos aleja del otro cierra
puertas una mirada sobre las habilidades
amplifica los logros fortalece empodera
genera un camino de crecimiento es
emocionalmente poderoso nos permite
avanzar
cada día sabemos más sobre la increíble
capacidad de cambio del cerebro y las
infinitas posibilidades que se asoman
sin importar la edad sin importar el
diagnóstico el cerebro cambia en
respuesta a la experiencia observemos
las experiencias completas de nuestros
hijos desde el movimiento de sus cuerpos
que ven que escuchan qué emociones están
involucradas qué pensamientos ideas
creencias cuál es el entorno
cada uno de nosotros tiene la opción y
tiene el derecho de tener el más grande
de los sueños para su hijo e ir en busca
de experiencias que expandan lo posible
y transformen la realidad nada menos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]